know that part in the show where they
introduced the band it's it's nice
it's nice but it's a do we care no no
but I understand why it's important for
the band members to be seen and
recognized no and it's also like you
know the the leads like the the star
doesn't want to be like hey it's all
about me this star is like pretending
star doesn't want to say hey look at me
right the star is pretending to be like
you know humble and gracious but it's
like we don't care
um I know that's mean to say like we
don't and they just tell you where
they're from like how long they've been
with the bed and then they do like a
little thing for the documentary okay
yeah we don't care